This video is brought to you by morning
brew,
the daily email newsletter covering the
latest news from Wall Street to Silicon
Valley.
More Info on morning brew at the end of
this video.
What's up guys?
Helen here.
If you ask anyone to explain why they
love Nathan for you,
they'll probably say some iteration of
good.
Just have to watch it.
Nathan fielder paints a bizarre picture
of America,
colored by strange individuals ranging
from the verbally abusive private
investigator.
You remind me of the wizard of
loneliness to the ex con Santa Claus to
the Stalker Esque Bill Gates
impersonator.
On one level,
Nathan's impossibly complex and
nonsensical plans belie analysis,
but as you already know,
that's not gonna.
Stop us because Paul,
all the insanity,
the show crackles with brilliant
commentary holding up a mirror to the
absurdity of running a modern business.
Welcome to this wisecrack addition on
Nathan for you and sort of maybe kind of
spoilers ahead.
Here's the premise of the show and your
typical episode of Nathan for you host.
Nathan fielder introduces us to one or
more struggling business owners and
proposals that cockamamie plan to
improve their luck.
You'll let minors purchase alcohol,
but then held it in a storage locker
until their 21st birthday,
a plaza liquor would gain a ton of new
underwriter customers.
Then we watch the plan escalate,
deviate,
and almost inevitably fail
for this mash up of retail and its
history.
Try and wreck on the most basic level.
Many of the plots,
Nathan,
can reveal something about the strained
relationship between morality and
economic realities.
To seriously are they talking about
putting a banner that says we sell
liquor to minors.
Nathan has described the way the series
was born,
partially out of his own obsession with
the 2008 economic collapse in which
risky bank behavior took down the global
economy.
What really fascinated him was the way
this cataclysmic fiscal rap was the
result of thousands and thousands of
seemingly mundane moments like when one
guy must have known his boss's credit
default swap magic was a bunch of woo in
nearly every episode of Nathan for you.
He makes us live through these kinds of
sickening moments after he pitched and
absurd sometimes immoral idea to a
business owner.
The plan turned the job of moving into
America's next fitness craze.
Watch each person reluctantly agreed to
ideas that will likely mislead.
Exploit the labor of insult or terrified
customer.
I think you'll get a lot more people if
they just think it's a workout and we
don't tell them that they're actually
doing free labor.
There's the antique store owner who
tepidly extends her business hours to
lauren drunk customers who are going to
fall prey to the stores.
You break it,
you buy it policy.
I just wouldn't prefer a broken item.
I'd rather sell a good one,
but yeah,
I mean it would be the same thing no
matter what happens.
So during each of these moments,
the owner's reluctance is palpable,
but it's typically eclipsed by their
desire to improve their business to
please Nathan.
Probably people will think that way.
Yeah.
Or simply just say on tv,
you know,
I want to see what,
how it works.
I would love to have this information
and then if I have the use,
yes,
why not?
She was engaged.
Typically they'll justify it as a means
of achieving bottom line profits
anytime.
Removing any product.
It's always beneficial to stores in this
subset of Nathan's pranks,
watching decent human beings cajoled
into small acts of immorality,
ranges from painfully uncomfortable to
flat out on believable.
Okay.
You know the drill,
right?
It's the last stop.
Take the time.
Nathan convinces this man that he's
being hired as a shell pr representative
enticed by the incentive of a good job.
The man is willing to say things like
this.
This mill right here,
this building a relatively small.
If you had to have a spill somewhere,
you would want this.
Bill Mason
highlights the way a system that
emphasizes personal gains at the expense
of community good sets up decent human
beings to become their worst selves,
and these are for people that you cut in
front of that you thought you were
better than including a nine year old
girl.
Part of the strength of Nathan satire
comes from the fact that each of his
ideas have some real world basis.
He takes business antics that we're
generally pretty comfortable with and
transports them to a place of queasy
moral,
including.
For example,
in the toy company episode,
he takes a familiar kind of advertising,
again,
targeted towards children owning a doin
kid is now the only proof that you are
not a baby here,
nice and reveals something uncomfortable
about businesses that stealthily exploit
or worst insecurities to get a piece of
our hard earned paycheck.
Nathan,
for you showcases the struggle of the
small business owner trying to compete
in the global economy.
Subverting the narrative that anyone
willing to work hard can simply pull
themselves up by their own bootstraps.
Nathan puts his own spin on the American
dream by first giving us the classic
protagonist,
a hardworking cab driver or electronic
store owner.
It's horrible.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's bad for small business and he
paints his own presence as the savvy
business consultant or the dose of luck
they need to revitalize their business,
but maybe there's a shortcut to actually
having brand recognition using a little
something called parody law.
What's the goal?
Isn't actually to help the businesses
find success.
It's to underscore the absurdity super
officiality and futility of modern day
business in the first place.
For instance,
even when his scheme to make an
elaborately orchestrated video,
that pig rescuing the golden a petting
zoo go viral,
actually worked.
He perversely left the zoo's name out of
the video.
I didn't want it to come across like an
ad for the petting zoo.
I thought it'd be a bit transparent so
that if people would have known that it
was old tree village can be so selfish.
This
mistake is a gag that actually gets to
the heart of the show's mission.
The short lifespan of any viral animal
video pretty much ensures the fact that
even if properly advertised,
the petting zoo would have quickly faded
back into cultural oblivion.
Nathan just expedited the process.
Even when Nathan's plans do succeed in
the short term,
they're typically two implausible to
survive in the longterm.
Los Angeles Health Department shut down
dumb starbucks yesterday because it did
not have proper permits.
Usually the business owner ends up
exactly where they started and just
maybe the show is highlighting the
impossibility of going up against big
business even when your plans are insane
and involve alligators.
This is never more clear than when
Nathan attempts to take on a global
brands.
In one episode,
he tries to help an electronic store
owner compete with best buy.
Their sales are ridiculous.
I mean there's no way that I can
compete.
Part of the problem is best buy's price
match policy in which they promise to
match any price from neighboring stores
preventing anyone from underselling them
faith and proposes.
They use price match against the company
by offering to sell TVs for $1,
which would allow them to stock up on
best buy's entire supply as expected.
Bestbuy finds a way out of it.
Why not?
They're not a competitor.
Of course,
at the same time that Nathan is trying
to use best buy system to his advantage,
he and the small store owner,
I'm going to even more elaborate and
absurd lengths to game their own
customers,
printing out some flyers and
distributing them throughout the
neighborhood.
It was finally time for Alan to offer
his $1 prices to the world,
obscuring their $1 TV's with a black tie
dress code and alive allocator.
After a failed ball suit and a staged
reality show,
we ultimately hear the message loud and
clear.
The international corporations can
design rules that plunge small
businesses into financial ruin.
I'm just so sick and tired of these big
companies like best buy and Ron thinking
that you know the rules don't apply to
them,
not content to suggest that the hyper
competitive business climate robs us of
our morality and doomed to failure.
The show also explores the uncomfortable
relationship between modern business
objectives and mortality.
To understand why this matters,
we have to examine the ideas of Pulitzer
prize winning.
Social Theorist Ernest Becker,
who saw the motivations behind our
desire to acquire money as simply put,
are futile efforts to escape death as he
wrote in his book,
escape from evil money can be
accumulated and passed on and so
radiates its powers even after one's
death,
giving one a semblance of immortality.
Nathan explores this relationship in
several of his episodes taking the logic
of acquisition and the narcissism
implicit in it and the plaza to the most
more bit of possible causes of funeral
industry.
In one episode,
he convinced us a funeral home to offer
a service in which the unpopular dead
can hire actors to attend their funerals
so that they appear to be well liked.
This is the ridiculous albion logical
extension of a consumer's world in which
we amassed objects and instagram likes
in order to feel hip,
cool and validated,
but there's more in other episodes.
Nathan explores the uncomfortable
aspects of monetizing the death.
He convinces a travel agent who only has
very elderly customers to start offering
funeral services to squeeze those
customers for every cent before they
quote.
He takes a very familiar logic,
diversifying your business,
and it makes it incredibly eerie by
literally capitalizing off deaths.
This is a last ditch effort to squeeze
out as much as you can from your
customers before they're gone for good.
By applying a pretty banal business
concept to the most ghoulish of
circumstances,
Nathan exposes the inherit culturism.
Sometimes implicit in trying to upsell
your customers towards the end,
it makes an attempt to save on the
overhead costs of cremations by testing
out the idea of using a wood fire pizza
oven instead of a crematorium.
A few more hours.
Would it all just burned to a crisp?
Yeah.
Would that work the same for a human
body?
At the same time,
there's actually a really strange
hopefulness.
Insincerity to Nathan for you.
Think about it.
This is one of the very few reality
shows in which the people depicted
typically don't come across as crazy
narcissistic jerks.
They're actually,
for the most part,
pretty sympathetic to show will often
stall on strange moments of humanity
even if it's somewhat disturbing like
the gas station owners propensity for
drinking his grandson's urine.
Bye.
I'm promoting because the ground
grandsons peer sometimes help or these
sexually experimental brothers,
so you guys are brothers
and you guys will have sex with the same
girl or the extremely ghost where a
realtor would choked in Switzerland
talking about earlier,
we are shocked by was by an entity.
Other times these displays of humanity
are just really genuine.
Going to be okay.
The show highlights the tension between
those slivers of humanity and the
mandates of our modern economy.
For instance,
in one scheme,
Nathan sets his production assistant
Solomon up on a date,
but agrees to have it sponsored by
Quiznos,
so a quiznos rep is brought on standby
to deliver branded dialogue in real time
for Solomon to say him say toasty.
Toasty.
This is a very self reflexive critique
of the television industry as a whole,
which at the end of the day,
only makes money by padding it's
gripping human dramas and comedies with
commercial breaks every 10 or so
minutes.
Furthermore,
if the show asks in a world over
saturated with advertising,
how can we hope for a true connection?
It shows best through line.
Explores this question by depicting
Nathan's ongoing quest to find love and
friendship.
Whether Nathan's forcing auditioning
actress to say,
I love you,
I love you again.
I love you
for asking a shopkeeper if he'd like to
hang out to be rejected.
Would you ever want to hang out
sometimes socially with me outside of
this?
No.
Nathan's antics are hilarious because
they're perfectly calibrated to turn
people off.
He's the king of inopportunity hugs and
misguided attempts at small talk.
If it makes it a little bit safer,
um,
would you be comfortable just being
handcuffed,
listen,
enjoys letting his genuine
vulnerabilities take center stage.
This is never more true than when Nathan
treats himself like a struggling
business
and I know that as a TV host,
having a personality that people don't
like is bad for business,
and that's why I needed to make a
change.
Scheming to improve is desirability.
As a friend and lover,
he paints himself as the hunk on a
meetup dating show.
He also conducts a focus group to
improve his likability.
I think v-neck would go well with you,
have been brilliant and stages and
elaborate scientific experiment to
improve that.
Hanging out with him is fun.
So if their serotonin or dopamine levels
go up when they're hanging out with me,
that would mean that I'm fun
in treating human interaction like a
business.
Nathan embodies the loneliness and
isolation of our modern world.
At other times,
Nathan actually offers an answer with
strange moments of genuine human
connectedness throughout the series,
solidarity forms amongst a troop of
rebates seekers who camp out with Nathan
on the mountain,
we agree with you.
The friendship that we gained here is
just incredible,
so let's go down the mountain,
and
an oddly compelling relationship
develops between Nathan antibodies,
most lovable sex worker facing happy
birthday.
He's interactions are always mediated by
money.
On some level,
the rebate seekers are waiting for
Nathan to get them their rebates and
macy as being paid handsomely to hang
out with him,
but glimmers of true curiosity,
affection and shared humanity shine
through and it's really beautiful to
watch.
It's adjusted.
Human connectedness is the bomb that can
make the current conditions of the
modern world terrible.
Sometimes.
Nathan literalize is this thesis by
sending the subjects of this failed
schemes up on dates,
suggesting that there's economic
situations could be bearable if only
they had love and conclusion.
Nathan for you is a giant smirk holding
a sign that says,
please love me.
It explores all the cynical motivations
that govern us in dys,
ruthless era of startups and branded
everything and hey,
at the end of the day,
maybe hanging out with the right group
of Weirdos could be just the antidote.
Unique.
Thanks for watching everyone piece,
but since we all have to have a job,
you're gonna want to stay informed about
the world of business rather than
getting bogged down by all those dents,
business news sites.
Consider cutting through the clutter.
With morning brew,
I used to work for a business journal,
so I've seen firsthand just how
inaccessible some of those sites can be.
Morning Brew is a free daily newsletter
that keeps you informed,
delivering the latest business stories
right to your inbox,
all in a punchy,
informative,
easy to understand email,
and you could subscribe for free in just
10 seconds at [inaudible] dot com or use
the link description.
I'd already heard lots of great stuff
about worrying brew and since I'm
practically obsessed with following the
shenanigans of big business,
I decided to give them a world and I've
loved it.
Now everyday I wake up to news on
Brexit,
what's going on with my shrink and
bitcoin balance,
the latest outrage over Ilan Lusk,
even though personally kind of a total
fan girl and tons more.
So if you're looking to quickly sharpen
your knowledge on everything from Wall
Street to Silicon Valley,
make morning brew a new part of your
routine.
Sign up for free by clicking the link in
the description.
We're going to morning brew dot Com.
Thanks for watching and catch you guys
next time.
Peace.